Ben's girlfriend's having this party I
don't know if we're going to go or not
it was him and his girlfriend and they
send us the flyer it's the sex party
it's just the flyer just a girl with [__]
all over her face and we were like well
I guess we got to go to that that
reminds me of the banana bread that my
mom made that had a cinnamon icing on
top how oh got it I was like how
interesting so we had similar New Year's
Eve mhm keep going no totally you
probably just like after you ate it
yeah
you guys get 40% off your first month
for a limited time at ritual.com
sltr Tuesday this offer is only
available through January 31st start
ritual or add essential for women
prenatal to your subscription today
that's ritual.com TR Tuesday for
40% off give your hair the hard reset
it's been asking for with living proof
go to livingproof tocom Tuesday and use
code trash Tuesday at checkout to get
15% off your order that's livingproof
docomo code trash Tuesday for 15% off
slags I am so excited I have two dates
left on my tour wait before that the
trailer to my movie drugstore June is
out now we have limited tickets
available for screenings with cast Q&A
it's going to be me Bobby Lee a bunch of
surprise cast members you can get
tickets to those at drugstore june.
comom that's going to be February 3rd in
New York and la and then tour dates
Portland Seattle my last two shows on
this tour before the baby happens um you
can get tickets at Esther on i.com I'll
be in Portland on January 18th and I
will be in Seattle on January 26th I
can't wait Esther on ice.com hi sluggy I
have so many amazing shows coming up I'm
doing a special one night only show with
one of my best friends in the whole
world Bonnie McFarland in New York City
One Night Only this uh Sunday the 21st
it's going to be incredible we have Tim
Dylan Mark Norman Lev fur you don't know
him but the other two are funny um it's
going to be so fun so get your tickets
before it sells out because it's gonna
go then I have my next Annie wooden
friends at The Comedy Store January 24th
I'm going to be in Denver Colorado
February 16th and 17th I have another
Annie wood and Friends February 20th I'm
going to be in Vancouver BC February
21st through 22nd and then March is a
crazy month I'm so excited I'm going to
be in Fort Worth Texas March 1st and 2nd
and then I'm coming back to New Mexico
you guys I have not been back to New
Mexico to perform since I left I'm going
to be in Albuquerque um the 8th and 9th
so please come to that of March it's
going to be absolutely wild I can't wait
I'm ecstatic about that and then I will
be finishing off the month in Washington
DC at the DC comedy L March 22nd and
23rd and my Jacksonville Florida shows
have been rescheduled for the end of
June so go to Annie letter.com shows I'm
always adding them I can't wait to see
you guys
um I'm so excited about my set and I
can't
wait welcome back to a brand fresh
freshy fresh new episode of trash
Tuesday today sitting in for Kila we
have a guess we've been wanting for so
long I am addicted to her she's so funny
she writes for SNL for SNL um please
welcome Rose Bud Baker thanks guys she's
also this goes without saying but one of
our standup comedy sisters yeah and she
has a big tour coming up and she just
was on Netflix verified which was so
good and like that was huge that was a
huge moment these past few months it was
fun I it was really I mean well I say it
was fun I was like eight and a half
months pregnant I barely remember it but
um but I am proud that I did it you know
what I mean it's like nice to like look
back and be like oh that's cool like I
can show this to her and you know also
the best she talk about her baby are
they they 20 minutes I'll show it to her
and she'll be like Mom this is you're a
loser but is there anything better to
like a like a special that's like short
so it's just like a preview to come see
you so you're not like oh here's
everything I've ever written and then I
have to write a whole new that's 8
Minute special I'm doing it day perfect
it's perfect and nobody watches more
than that anyway no one needs an hour I
know I had just shot an hour too but I
had shot an hour and then they were like
uh can you do this eight minutes and I
literally wrote like jokes and then just
did it so you did all different yeah oh
my God that's Brave yeah well it was
like not brave cuz at the moment I was
just like this could be a failure and I
don't care but it's not it's such a
funny set like people need to watch it
on Netflix Netflix verified and there's
also a bunch of other funny people on
there too yeah it's awesome yeah it's a
good group Robbie Hoffman is hilarious
Robie Hoffman cracks me the [__] is so
funny God she so funny crazy she's such
a good show okay so now eser we have to
come out with Esther being fake pregnant
um Esther has gotten less pregnant since
I saw her faking her pregnancy this is
my worst fear because you know when you
have a stomach ache and your dad's like
yeah right get up like this is how I
feel what's happening I imagine you are
just this is just a stomach ache this is
a very important stomach long stomach
really serious stomach a I was telling
the girls earlier um I started chewing
this flavorless gum that I found from
turkey and then this guy dm'd me and was
like that's what incels use to like get
their jaw chiseled I'm sorry but wait
why what incels have chiseled Jaws right
they that's what I'm curious about like
it's like the huberman Bros I just
picture like the guys out there they
want a better job because that's how
they they it's easier that way it's
easier wait we had a win against the
incels did you have you guys in chat
Hank's last post look at this look at
this can you put the sound message to
fake Alpha [__] ass literally he's pod
clip talking about the turn signal being
a high value man or you know girls
women's body counts and they got to be
virgins
like how you know if you make over
[__] 100K and [__] if you're 6'
three and dudes complaining bro I'm
going to lose mying mind you nerds stop
complaining Jesus Christ oh my God it's
clear that you
mother will you is he still driving will
you interpret this for me like what's
the dis of this message he's saying sick
of hearing all these Alpha guys on
podcast like talking about how like
they're high value men and high value
women need to have be like virginal and
have never had sex and he's like you
guys are nerds you've never been laid
you've never gotten like this is so
embarrassing shut the up cuz I've just
been like what is the by the way also
even if you look at like an Andrew Tate
it's like guys he has like prostitutes
around him who have banged a hundred
guys and he's paying them and you're
like listening to his rhetoric he's just
like playing all these incels wow that
is I'm really proud of I didn't know
Chad Hanks was going to be my king and
he's my king he is my king and something
I knew he was going to I knew he was
going to be your king I know it's like
Kevin F fell so going to be there he's
your type yeah yeah I feel like he uh
stopped driving halfway through that he
was he was doing a lot of hand talking
maybe he's a Tesla I was just concerned
I'm like I still see the background
moving I know your foot is on the
accelerator but where's the steering
wheel I once there's a female comedian
who was um when um what was the the app
everyone was using that went out of
business that was like a live streaming
we used to periscope you forg I just
can't remember my
bra Periscope she was periscoping and
she got in a carent on the Periscope and
it's so funny did you know that Tik Tok
will not allow you to live stream while
you're in a car it'll shut down your
live streamow so I have no career CH
knows everything China they know they
know when you're driving we support the
state of China whatever you are we
actually love China so much whatever you
are whatever you want to be today we we
will sponsor you actually um I did not
know that Tik Tok wouldn't let you live
stream but I've also never once ever
tried to live stream on TI Tok you're
well adjusted and you're let's not say
things we can't take back um but yeah no
I've never tried it wait so okay
obviously I'm going crazy over here
because you just had a baby and like you
seem like you're fine yeah I am so
that's really great it's a shock to me
too I was pretty sure I was going to be
like depressed or anxious or like I was
like mostly scared of um of postpartum
depression I was like that's going to
hit me hard I just felt like it was
going to be me but it was actually my
husband it hit my husband my husband got
like anxiety like for real bad bad
postpartum anxiety which I was like
that's a woman's disease you can't take
that from me but he did he he had was it
just the anxiety of like being
responsible for a life it no it was like
anxiety about like chemicals in the air
and like would she be able to breathe
like all of this [__] and I was just
like oh God isn't that the craziest
thing about pregnancy like we go through
all this [__] and then you just look
over at the guy and he's like I need to
figure out if I can get weed in Atlanta
like Dave not now yeah I know they're
just like they're not worried at all but
at the end he started freaking out about
anything that he fed me he was like I
think there was kimchi in that and that
has like that has like chem and I was
like oh this is starting to feel a
little like while you were pregnant yeah
I was like it's starting to feel a
little kooky but it was like the bigger
I got the more real it got to him and so
he started worrying about like [__] that
I was eating or [__] that I was doing
and then when she was born it was like
oh God he he kept leaving our hospital
room to go check on the baby in the
nursery at the hospital so I was like oh
he can't sleep like he can't sleep OCD
yeah yeah did any part of you like it or
get turned on when he was so overly
caring about what food you put in your
body no you're so like that eating
disorder girl you're like she is like so
awesome of a guy put me on a
diet he's count does it turn you on when
he counts your calories oh I love when
it man just looks over everything I eat
passion it my lifelong dream is for like
a corporation to decide what I'm allowed
to eat and what I'm not allowed well I
would love it if you I want you to swing
the other way and I want to be like your
feeder if you decide you just want to
get really big I wanted that for this
pregnancy and I'm really upset because I
can't eat a lot and I I need to stop
complaining I'm very grateful um Esther
the fact that you can't eat a lot is
really uh it's a blessing cuz I'm
telling you if your size if you were
able to eat as much as I was able to eat
you die we're listen we're all surprised
we're happy and we're surprised we're
pleasantly surprised by what's happened
with but I'm also like still obviously
gaining weight and I'm still getting
like the food that I need to get in but
if I was not pregnant and the way I feel
I would be eating I wouldn't be able to
eat like it's just so hard but um
what I forgot what I was GNA say
something just about how skinny I am I
don't know I how pretty I am during this
pregnancy really making me glow skinny
and pretty and
teenaged um is Dave like more into you
do you think is he having a little
pregnancy fetish so loving and
supportive he's being when I saw him in
the green room when you were being I
thought you were being wild and he was
like no she's being great I was like Wow
Dave's turn he loves me for the first
time and it's really wonderful are you
afraid it's not you that he loves and
when it comes out he'll choose baby over
you not I feel like she's like I'm not
but thanks for
planting I'm only here to help um what's
interesting is that I asked Esther the
same thing I asked you Rose Bud which is
like do you want to kill your husband
every day when you're pregnant because
he's just all he had to do was orgasm to
have this happen and Esther was like no
actually he's like really sweet and I
was like really and then she was like
no I wanted to kill him every day which
is how I would be yeah it didn't matter
how nice he was being to me I was just
mad that I had to do it you know I was
just mad that I had to do it and that he
was like got to be like living his life
and just doing whatever you know what I
mean like it wasn't hard for him
physically it's really surprising like I
don't know why I'm still surprised by
that that we really do it all yeah yeah
I know and then you think you're like
shouldn't men just be serving us at all
times and just be no we should be laying
in bed being fed chocolates like that's
there's a part of our cycle where that's
what we're supposed to be right we're
we're supposed to be invalids just being
fed
chocolate no I feel like it was like it
wasn't about him like I was just mad at
the setup of the world like I was just
mad that we had to do it and that it's
like they don't have to and I and then I
was on tour and I was like I was still
working it's like now and we're expected
to work cuz it's like God forbid you
have a kid and then everybody just
assumes that you don't give a [__] about
your career and you're like that's not
the case like I'm still who I am and you
know what I mean so it was just like it
got really complicated I do feel like
stressed about like I'm the bread
winner and the yeast maker of my
household um but I like it's if I got
pregnant right now it's like my body on
the road is what makes me and like
supports my family so I'm like what that
would be so hard I wouldn't be able to
get off the road at all yeah it's hard
it's really hard but at the same time
it's doable like you think that it's
impossible and then you're you're going
through it and you're like I can do this
it's really hard but I can do it well
you just probably something I'm I would
just guess like it just kicks in the
road is hard anyway the road feels like
torture anyway so it's just it's the
same I'm trying to change my um views on
that because I did this thing I went to
San with a bunch of my girlfriends that
I do iasa with and we had like a little
like hippie bringing in New Year week
this past weekend you did iasa this past
weekend I didn't do iasa this past
weekend I'm doing it next weekend but um
okay I did K I did some ketamine
treatments and some mushrooms maybe too
many mushrooms honestly I might be done
with mushrooms it was wild what happened
really so jealous it was crazy no you
would have been so mad at yourself if
you took the amount of mushrooms I took
what was so bad we were walking well I
lived in Santa Fe for seven years so I'm
in this ghost town of like so many like
different lives I could have Liv which
is amazing I love going there but it was
like it was very intense on mushrooms
and we're walking down Canyon Road and
snowing and it was like Canyon Road is
where they have all these like art
galleries and every painting is like
breathing and I'm it was just so much
and I was like my feet I was wearing my
get nauseous and sick I feel like that's
what happened I didn't get nauseous and
sick I had to take a [__] and there were
like no bathrooms it was just like I
know and then it just easily came out I
just did a little push and it came up
but um but my feet I was wearing uggs
and my feet were wet and I couldn't I
was so high on mushrooms I couldn't tell
if my feet were wet or I was making it
up and then when I realized they were
wet I kept going like is this a lesson
in not making a problem about my feet
being wet and just going with the group
oh I like that or is this the opposite
and am I being a doormat and I need to
tell the group I love that even more yes
you're like am I walking on myself and
then I just got new boots yeah but it
was like it was just too many intense
decisions and just a very simple your
feet are wet you're in the snow you need
to get some snow boots this is you're
going to get hypothermia right like it
would have been a lot easier just figure
that out yeah if I was sober would have
been like can we find a shoe store I'll
see you guys in a second but I was like
I needed to be basically Babys you
turned it into these huge life decisions
and what does this say about my
childhood but um but we did this thing
we rented this like big mansion and we
did this thing it was like an end of the
year review and then like a
manifestation for the next year like it
was like 20 Pages yeah and they had you
go through your calendar of the last
year and see all the like big B
Milestones that you had and I was on the
road every day like I I felt last year I
felt um lazy I felt like I didn't do
enough I had all these like thoughts
about myself and then I look back and
I'm like oh my God I worked so [__]
hard and I was so proud of myself so now
I'm trying to look at the road as like
appreciative of myself for like getting
up getting there doing this traveling
you also do love it I feel like the way
you talk about it it's like you love it
you do
you wanted it for so long that but it's
yeah it is complicated cuz it's also
like sometimes you're in a middle seat
and coach and sometimes you're never am
I in a middle SE coach I will go I will
be I will knock my teeth out and give
[__] on the street I'll buy
new I will give the best gummy [__]
to strangers stay first is this okay I
don't want to give her any ideas Annie
she's getting older you might not need
to knock them out you just wait it out
oh my God my beautiful mother who made
me cinnamon vegan banana bread you to be
loving your mom more than usual obessed
with my mom I'm happy it's really weird
are you is that like a pregnancy thing
uh I do feel I feel like I owe my mom a
lot of apologies yeah well you know what
I mean I do love my mom we're very
different my mom and I and I love her to
death I do feel like having a baby I'm
just like oh my God you're like aing
Angel like I don't know how you did what
you did you're I'm like Amazed by what
she did it's crazy but I also like I
took my actually yes I think it's true I
took my mom on a trip to Italy while I
was pregnant a like just to like show
her Italy cuz I was like I wanted to
give her a trip so yeah I guess I was
kind of obsessed with her did she have
to take care of you on the trip motherly
yeah yeah she did that's the bonus mom
we do we'll do our trip when my acid
reflux is gone okay we'll do that after
the baby comes out but yeah no I she'll
be carrying all of your love
and the baby yeah I feel so much more
like connected are you going to let her
in the delivery room that I don't know I
think it well I don't know I'm not I
feel like that's between me and Dave
yeah that's that's a you and Dave thing
you don't want to no doctors you're not
going to live stream it you a moment no
doctors just you and Dave yeah let him
figure it out that's this is his moment
to step up um wait Rose Bud because
we're talking about drugs are you
seriously sober yeah how yeah I've been
sober for 15 years wow yeah so oh God
how do you that's my I'm having my 15
year no alcohol too yeah that's a good
one how do you kick back and get get it
out I think you stay I think if you're
sober for long enough you just don't
care like it's like you're kind of
always kicked back cuz it's like do you
feel like you have a vice in life this
vaping cute yeah I can't stop can't stop
with to nicotine is my favorite thing in
the world iasa let me ask you about iasa
does it help it's doesn't seem like it's
helping anybody oh my God it's
absolutely unbelievable it's so it's so
incredible it's crazy what does it help
I feel completely changed I feel like
I'm able to handle life in a different
way see things differently I'm not like
afraid of death I'm not I don't live
life fearfully anymore yeah I feel
really I I love it were you afraid of
death before I was afraid of my dad's
death a lot I was like really really
scared of losing other people you're
like Dad I did drugs and now I don't
care if you die no the first time I did
the first time I smoked DMT I literally
called my dad and I was like die when
you die it's going to feel so good you
can die now he was like Jesus
Christ he's like to who yeah yeah that's
like the by the way the literal opposite
of pregnancy it's every night at 4:00
a.m. I'm like no one's allowed to die
like this is really scary well now like
a reason to live too it's like you want
to like be there for your kids my
brother my mom for my 18th birthday with
my twin brother she was going to get us
skydiving yeah and then our 18th
birthday came around and she just forgot
she told us that even though it was two
against one we're like No And she was
like I never said I'd do that and we're
like all right so we never went and then
years later I wanted to go with him and
he's like I have kids I don't want to go
skydiving anymore I get it I get it yeah
whoa I was talking to Duncan Trestle and
his wife too a couple years ago when I
was in Texas and they were saying
because I was like let's go to Burning
Man and they're like we just don't like
have that now that we have kids we just
don't want to both be going somewhere
and you know yeah do you how do you feel
like you've changed so far since baby
born it's weird like everything changes
and and but you're still the same it's
weird I don't know like I'm like I'm
here right and I am I'm still having a
great time it's great to see everybody
but I'm not like I would rather be
hanging out with her and she can't even
talk so I'm was just like this is weird
that I'm like and then I'll go home and
I'll and I'll be with her and I'm like
you're not doing anything like I'm just
like come on like pick it up but
watching her like come online and start
to smile and start to like do like
little koi [__] where she smiles and she
like turns away from you and then she
like looks to see if you're like smiling
you know what I mean like that kind of
[__] is just I I can't it feels like I
keep saying this but it feels like the
thing that heroin is trying to do but
it's but like fails like it's like you
can't it doesn't even like heroin could
never you know what I mean that's so
inspiring it feels crazy good and in
spite of how [__] terrible pregnancy
was I like the second that they showed
me my daughter I was like holy I would
ruin my life 10 times over just to like
get this feeling again but also you
wouldn't right cuz you're done at one
I'm done at one but it's it's hard cuz
you're like my pregnancy was really
tough it it was really tough and if it
wasn't so physically like traumatic I
would do it again did you think that it
was going to be or were you kind of
blindsided by it I kind of knew it I
kind of knew pregnancy wasn't for me I
was actively looking for surrogates when
I got pregnant but um yeah I was
actively like cuz I wanted a kid but I
didn't want to do it myself yeah you
know what I mean and um I I was like
it's impossible like with my job with
the road and also like I'd had two
miscarriages so I was like I don't want
to go through this again yeah yeah and
then I got pregnant and I was like and
then 10 weeks later I was like I guess
this is for Real cuz I had never made it
past I think well I had made it to like
11 but I I had had like what's called a
missed miscarriage so that's what I had
too yeah so that was like tricky yeah
it's like not until you get to that 12
week Mark where you're like okay I guess
I should start taking this seriously
yeah now is there anything that you
maybe like would have wanted to do like
skydiving but probably not that I hope
um you're not as crazy as Annie oh my
God you're such a square I know so nerd
I'm like I feel like by the way the
Alaska Airlines the flight where the
door like the whole piece of the plane
came off you would have been like yes
like if I survived it yeah i' be like oh
my God I survived this yeah I'm a
manaster you would have been so like
annoying after that cuz you would have
just been like punching walls like
trying to break things like having
everything go wrong you get in your car
you punch a hole through the window I
knocked the other one the other door out
yeah I open all the emergency the pilots
have to like restrain you oh my God but
wait so is there anything though that
you're like oh I wanted to like go to
Coachella and now I'm like I would never
do that no I never wanted to go to
Coachella in my life obv I've never I
don't don't really love big gatherings
me either I don't like
festive I hate Musical music festivals
musical festivals listen to me I hate
Music Festival that sounds really good I
know when you said musical I was like
Esther is like GNA be so
triggered a musical maybe this is your
next career yeah what you're a you're a
podcaster you're a comedian
you're actress you're a filmmaker and
you put on an epic Festival musical F by
the way I'm in musical festivals yeah
how do those not exist Fest musical cons
Esther Fest is so perfect we call it
music musical con that does not sound
good eser I'll produce it with you okay
thank you I feel like we can definitely
get the crazy exgirlfriend fans out easy
yeah I know you actually were in a
[__] musical I know I don't know how
that happened I'm so that was truly an
accident CU I really cannot sing you
have been only good or you been only in
good things thank you for saying that I
mean don't look too deep on the IMDb but
just believe believe in yourself right
now don't check it out too hard just
stay there where you're at mentally so
it like no but nothing I'm not like uh
there's nothing that I wanted to do
before that I don't want to do now
because she's there except uh work oh
you don't want to work like I want to
because I love what I do yeah but I um
I'd rather be with her but I also don't
want to have a kid that has a mom that
gave up on working like I'm like it's
really important to me my mom's a
painter and she had five kids and by the
time five of them were here she was like
I'm not painting she for years she
didn't paint and I remember being like
bummed out by that so to me it's really
important to has she since you guys have
grown up did has she started painting
again yeah yeah my mom's having like a
real Renaissance it's really cool my mom
wrote like 100 books pic it's crazy what
happens it's like once the kids are out
and they get their groove back it'sing
awesome to see cuz you get to see your
mom like really like and I just I just
don't want my kid to ever miss out on
seeing me that way while she's growing
up because I I mean I'm sure she's going
to grow up and resent me regardless but
I it's like you know you sort of pick
and choose like what you want to be well
they have to we talked about this on
another thing there was this this Theory
I heard this some internet Guy saying
about how when kid kids the reason kids
rebel against their parents and start to
think their parents are losers is
because during their reproductive age
group which is like unfortunately 13 to
25 they have to naturally be disgusted
with their family because they need to
leave the village and not have incest
yeah yeah yeah and so at 25 we come back
mhm okay I kind of only I I maybe left
like I was bad at 13 yeah but it I came
back quick at 14 like I was like there's
nothing else out there for me my mommy
makes my sandwiches and makes my bed
like I'm coming back home oh my God this
is real this is real yeah I'm like oh my
God this this is for Real Her trauma is
the the amount they they burrito her in
a also like you guys are like my our
mom's had this artistic career I'm like
no my mom's her career is taking care of
me that's I think for a lot of I think
that's like a creative thing too I'm now
I'm realizing like oh it's like you know
if I lived in the middle of nowhere and
I wasn't and I worked at Enterprise Rent
A Car I having kids would be my way of
being creative do you know what I'm
saying so it's like there's a cre it is
a creation it's a creative impulse you
know what I mean and I think that's why
it takes look at Trisha pis she's the
most creative mommy on the planet who is
that Trisha you don't know who Trisha
pis is oh this is going to get weird
what babe I don't know who anybody is
she's this like amazing YouTuber who
just became a mommy in the last couple
years and it's just like her whole she's
just nailing motherhood on Tik Tok
somehow and on YouTube she's just like
she does this like Tavern character in
her basement and then she like
entertains her kid with it but it's also
funny on Tik Tok okay it's also not
funny like it's weird her gender reveal
outfits were so cute she's always her
husband she's always like putting her
husband in outfits and stuff it's so
funny it's like you're going to have to
send me this will yeah the pitch is not
not Pitch isn't is killing but yeah I
don't think I don't think it would yeah
yeah yeah that's fair I feel like a big
question mark that I um like think about
a lot other than what horrible Massacre
will my birth be is will I like want to
keep working or will I want to just
totally devote my life to my baby or is
it the most likely thing which is like
I'll want both it depends like you I'm I
want both I want to I want to keep
working and I want to hang out with her
and want to bring her with me and like
you know I have one kid so I'm like I
can kind of do that what are your SNL
hours that's a bad question yeah I don't
know how to answer that it's like it
depends I thought you were going to say
that's the greatest question you've ever
heard I was like oh my God I feel like
that's like the best question yes you're
like it's such a professional question
cuz isn't it like you guys work it just
depends all night for like Tuesday is
like writing night and you work all
night and then but I I like you know
Tuesday and Wednesday I don't go into
work until like 300 p.m. a lot of the
day I'm with her and then I come home a
little bit late and I you know like she
wakes up in the middle of the night and
I'm there to like feed her in the middle
of the night so it doesn't feel like I'm
missing too much actually like the only
days that I really feel like I'm missing
are like all of Saturday yeah and then
um I miss like bedtime Tuesday and I
miss no that's it Tuesday is the only
day that I like Miss B time yeah so
how's it been in the entertainment
industry after you've had a child it's
like I mean it's easy in the sense that
it's the same you know like I don't feel
any different but there's there is like
it's soing toxic the way that women are
like supposed to like Snap Back and like
we're supposed to be like on top of our
game and we're but because you do I'm I
do feel significantly Dumber because I'm
my brain is like I'm spread soing thin
that it's just you know I don't remember
like I literally texted you yesterday
and was like how was the glucose thing
and then this morning we talked about it
and then this morning I texted her again
how was the glucose thing and was like
wait we covered this never mind like
Whitney was saying that to me too
yesterday she was like Mom brain's real
it is real it is real is it because
you're thinking about it's cuz you're
thinking about 17 things that the same
okay but I feel sharper at the I also
feel sharper because I can do more than
I ever thought I could do because I'm
just it's like survival so it's it is
It's Tricky but you figure it out you
know what I mean and it's like there's
nothing to worry about because whatever
you decide that's going to be the thing
you want so why would you feel you know
what I mean like I was so worried that I
wouldn't want to do standup anymore I
was so worried that I wouldn't want to
do but now that I'm in this I'm like if
I chose not to do standup anymore it's
because I want to be with my kid so I'm
still choosing the thing that makes me
happiest so there's really nothing to
like worry about did I ever tell you
guys when I first started dating Dave
like a month in I was like I I've got
Dave I think I don't in my head I'm like
I don't need to work anymore and I one
morning I was like I think I'm going to
quit standup and like a couple hours
later Dave was like I think it's really
weird that you're suddenly quitting the
thing you do and I was like yeah okay
never mind I like walk it back wait I
also want to tell you about the glucose
test so it's this like thing that you do
in pregnancy in 28 weeks where you have
to drink this like syrupy sugar drink
and then wait an hour and they test your
blood sugar whatever is it to save
you're diabetic or gestational diabetes
yeah and online everyone's like it's so
horrifying it tastes like syrup you're
going to be so nauseated it's so gross
so for six months I've been like I'm so
scared it's going to make me sick I
literally loved it it was so good it was
aw soing good you're like delicious can
I have another so good yeah I thought it
was gross but I I wasn't like this isn't
the worst thing I've ever tried like
clearly you guys well you have a history
of a sweet tooth I don't know where
you're at these days I just know where
you were when we became friends there's
a lot of bags of gummy bears yes I love
gummy bears there was things around
there were gummy things gummy shapes all
sorts of being fed to you by your keeper
by my roommate keeper I had a roommate
was my keeper when I met Esther she was
living in a studio apartment with a a
woman an avocado air and um she was oh
my God had like a small little my own
little bed yeah and she was cared for we
slept in the same room I love I've I've
never been that's so nice yeah I'm like
Dave should we get separate beds so it
feels more like when you're moving into
Dave you were like Annie do you want to
move in here I was living in my car I
was like I think I need to stay in the
car I remember I remember you wanting to
move in I had there was options but I I
remember I couldn't do I was like I
can't I would have I I don't think I
would have thrived in that situation how
long ago was this that was probably like
20 14 years 12 or 11 13 or 14 years ago
okay yeah yeah yeah did you at a camp
like no I couldn't sleep over yeah see
I'm I didn't either so I feel like I'm
always trying to have that experience
like Camp ruled I love Camp was so good
being in a room with someone and like I
I never was like oh I need to be at my
parents house I was never like that
always wanted to be like gone I was like
I want to be out I want to go yeah I was
like there's so many times I tried to
run away like just for just to see you
know what I mean come for you I wasn't
even mad I was just like I'm going to go
just see what happened yeah nobody
noticed they were just like we have five
kids get lost they can afford when I was
13 they were ready for me to leave the
village they were like get out one other
thing that I wanted to bring up earlier
that I forgot was the reason that not
being able to eat a lot right now now
like I because the acid reflux it makes
it so I can only eat a small amount and
I have to be eat very Bland Foods a lot
is coming up for me because I have a
very serious emotional dependence on
being able to eat what I want and I'm
like I feel like I'm going through that
on top of it all where I'm just like oh
I have to sit with my uncomfortable
feelings and I don't know I'm just are
you finding other things to do are you
journaling or anything I am journaling a
lot I'm journaling a lot with these
nails isn't it God like oh my Palms
hurt like I'm just speaking into Siri
dict dear diary like what do you guys do
when you're the discomfort hits I don't
know I take a special little drug called
semi glutide and it I no longer have
those things I just eat like a regular
person now really uhuh wow so how is it
going I I really like it it's helping my
brain a lot what is it how is it
affecting you I just am not having like
obsessive thoughts I just eat I'm hungry
I'm having a very different experience
than everyone else that I've heard
that's on it everyone's like my stomach
hurts I'm not hungry I'm like no I'm
hungry I just eat really regular meals
you're not getting nauseous not even a
little bit nothing's no bad if I yeah
most people are like I can't eat on OIC
yeah and you're like maybe I'm not on
the same dose as them or something okay
but I don't even have like a will to
lose weight anymore like before I was
like oh I could lose some weight now I'm
on it I'm like oh I feel great you're
just like at peace on it yeah yeah it's
that's like me on weed I'm it's just
like oh that fixed things when I'm on
weed I'm like what did I say yesterday
oh my
god what have I
done I'm like so I get like so doubtful
and filled with shame when I smoke weed
it's so bad for me yeah it's not for me
eser is that the thing you miss the most
would you say weed I would have said
that in the beginning and now I just
want to not have a sour taste in my
mouth I just want to be comfortable like
I want to feel comfortable you want to
give birth that's really what it is yeah
and the other thing too is it's like
there's a lot of thoughts about what's
the postpartum going to be and it's like
I just want to get on the other side and
be on the journey to recovery so it's
weird that like I'm these next three
months are just that's what I want okay
so are you feeling like impatient like
you wish you could like snap your
fingers in the baby's here or do you
feel like you need three months to be
like prepared to take care of it no I
want it I want this over I'll figure it
out on the spot that's fine yeah I don't
care I felt that way too I was like
pretty sure I got this I just am so
uncomfortable I want to be I want to
feel better and nine months is such an
interesting like time period because
it's so much time and also so little
time it's like it's actually 10 months
too it's always like it's longer I don't
really know how like I can't do the math
but there's a couple of like trimester
or there's like certain trimesters that
are like more than [__] 12 weeks or
whatever but anyway yeah it's hard when
it's over it's you are so crazy what a
while wait what do you mean like what do
you mean like you just I can't describe
it I just like was crying I maybe it's
cuz I haven't cried I literally didn't
cry for like so long that when I when
she was born I was like why can't I stop
I can't stop crying like and then my mom
my mom actually to her credit knew this
and I did not know this like I kept
putting the baby down to go cry cuz I
was like I don't want to like [__] up
the baby with like my me like sobbing
over her I'm my mom was like no you need
to lie down on the couch I'm going to
put the baby on your chest and you will
feel better and I didn't know that the
baby actually makes you feel better like
I had no idea that that actually like
lowers your anxiety levels and like
raises your oxytocin and like I just
didn't know any of that I just thought I
was like oh I don't want to like piss
her off like crying all over my frozen
Embry are kegling right now by the way
they're in a freeer just
kegling I will say donut provides that
comfort for me like she how do you feel
about your how many dogs do you have um
one one dog how do you how did you feel
about your dog when your daughter was
born I don't care yeah it's different
now right I don't care like I forget I
forget you don't care about the dog I
don't oh my gosh I love her yeah of
course but I don't think about her this
won't be me it will it won't be I will
check in and be honest when it happens
but I don't I it can't you know what I'm
imagining you know what I should say
there's definitely a possibility that it
could because I
this is what I want for you I want there
to be a baby carrier that for twins and
I want baby and dog in baby carrier Dave
keeps being like donut that's sister
like your sister is coming yeah that's
her primary name in our household is
donut sister but I know it'll change and
also do you have a name kind of Dave
like told it to two of his friends and
they had a really negative reaction tell
people the name I know you can't I'm
also like they're losers Dave like who
cares yeah it's going to be a swing also
his name is Dave and yours is Esther so
it's like anything you do is going to be
good yeah he has a normal name you
have you have a cool name it's cuz those
names are coming back it's comeing
around but it was a rough how do you
feel about your name cuz you have a like
unique name I like it you have you did
you not like it when you were like like
no I mean I was called Bud my whole
childhood I love so I'm like I don't you
know roseb is like the feminine version
of that and then yeah I just I've always
liked like weird names I've always liked
them yeah me too yeah banana bra banana
bra thank you so
much did you know Annie that 95% of
pregnant women are not on the show
talking to me about my huge life choice
every day they're not getting their
recommended daily intake of key Omega-3s
okay and that is why ritual I cannot
tell you how this has saved me during
pregnancy you know what too is so fun
about it we actually just put a funnel
into her mouth and we just pour the
powder straight in and it absorbs her
acid reflux their prenatal contains 350
milligrams of eco-friendly vegan omega-3
DHA in every serving Source from algae
algae oil instead of fish and it's also
important to take a prenatal before
you're pregnant like their prenatal
vitamin has all of the right things they
Source their ingredients in a really
great way that I'm not explaining well
but they have omega-3 DH to support your
baby's brain development choline which
you've never heard of it but then you
get pregnant and it's very important and
it's hard to get that so the prenatal
multivitamin has choline and methylated
folate to support baby's neural tube
development the capsules feature a
delayed released and they are rigorously
tested and validated by a third party
and also the ritual essential protein I
make a daily Shake I add this pregnancy
and postpartum protein in there it has
all the things I need it's female found
founded they use scientific tools to
lower carbon packaging they're just it's
awesome I'm so excited that they are
finally sponsoring us Sor I had to get
pregnant first why settle for a
multivitamin you're not 100% sure about
ritual was literally built on trust so
you know it's the real deal get 40% off
your first month for a limited time at
ritual.com TR Tuesday this offer is only
available through January 31st start
ritual or add essential for women
prenatal to your subscription today
that's ritual /tr Tuesday for 40% off
DraftKings casino is bringing you only
the best Classics like Blackjack
roulette and Slots plus exclusive games
you won't find anywhere else Annie you
have been talking about DraftKings all
month I'm so excited because it download
the DraftKings casino app now and use
code trash Tuesday new players get an
instant deposit match up to $100 in
Casino credits when you deposit $5 or
more that's code trash Tuesday only on
DraftKings Casino the the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler or
visit www.1 1800 gambler. net and
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
8887895118
hours of registering new account Max
match $100 in Casino credits which
require one time playthrough within 7
Days 168 hours see terms at casino.
draftkings.com slne player offer 2024
you know it really is that time of year
where I want a hard reset and my hair is
one of those places where I'm like I
need I want my hair to be cute I want it
to look good I want it to look clean
thank you to living proof's clarifying
detox shampoo my hair is getting that
reset it needs and is feeling clean and
healthy I swear by this dry shampoo it
is literally the best and I I have seen
all the sluggy are so excited that we
have a living proof sponsor because they
already use them they already love them
and by the way we are living proof that
living proof works we are I mean this is
I when we got this sponsor I was
screaming also living proofs products
are uniquely formulated to address the
root cause of your hair concern and
never to just conceal it which is what
most other brands do and if you're not
sure what product your hair needs
instead of guessing I personally started
by taking living proof's AI online Hair
Care quiz which analyzes your specific
Hair Care needs and styling goals and
then uses a first tomarket technology to
help customize the right hair care
routine for you or for me and they
always this is the most important thing
especially during baby time they
formulate without silicons harsh
sulfates SLS SLE parabens and phalates
they're also pea certified crueltyfree
color safe and safe for chemically
treated hair thank you give your hair
the hard reset it's been asking for with
living proof go to livingproof
docomo and use the code trash Tuesday at
check out to get 15% off your order
that's livingproof tocom Tuesday code
trash Tuesday for 15% off livingproof
tocom TR Tuesday code trash Tuesday
Annie and I have been using living proof
on the road the dry shampoo for 10 years
I can't believe they're our sponsor I
know it's shocking you guys get get on
board something very interesting that
has happened like we did a poll about
sex preferred sex time this is a big
shift from pregnancy and babies but are
you morning sex or afternoon sex I'm no
sex thank
you got that part sewn up too right how
did you not offer night sex sorry night
sex I'm a night sex person so I don't
know why I didn't no night sex nightx
night sex right yeah I feel like a lot a
lot of men are mourning men are mourning
sex cuz their testosterone levels are
the highest in the morning I like
morning sex with a you where you just
cry
yeah you suffer you suffer all your
losses at once I love a spelling joke on
a
body good girl big guys I'm learning big
girl I'm definitely sex because it's
more intimate because you smell and
you're like grosser but
like when part care it's like nice no no
I've definitely married my soulmate I
don't want to smell him you know what I
mean I love him but I don't want to
don't stink I do love that Todd like
does not will not go out un showered and
it's a little annoying sometimes cuz I'm
like don't you want to go on a walk we
go to the coffee shop or whatever and
he's like no he has to shower that's
really fascinating this is one thing
that I have to say I love about Dave but
also sometimes I'm like well it's just
he's the perfect guy for me cuz he and I
will forget to shower for a long time
and I love that cuz I I people like I
remember when I would hang out with
Benji all the time he would he would
shower like three times a day but like I
do find comfort in like a guy that's
just like dirty right and doesn't care
about his own cleanliness although I
just don't want like them go herck go
watch scrub that scrub that [__] up is
Todd Catholic was he Catholic no no he
just likes to be clean I love how I'm
like there needs to be a serious reason
why he showers cuz that's imagine Tad
was just really religious and I never
told you
wait did you really get the greatest
snake of all time a huge snake I got
wait what we have six snakes how are we
just now bringing this up we have six
snakes because guys you have real
children no I but six
snakes new snake I sent this to everyone
in my family my new snake I was going to
bring him but I didn't know if you're
were scared of snakes I don't care if
thank you for not bringing him no no no
I don't care if you're scared I've known
you too long [__] this is a third year
this is the third year it's not I don't
have a picture of him up there it was on
our story it's big though it looked like
Britney Spear snake so awesome what kind
of snake he is a butter itchy it's a boa
he's so cute okay so my next episode of
annwood he's around my neck the whole
time and then he's his tails are on here
and he's holding the mic to me if I can
train I don't know if this is possible
if I can train this snake to move
microphones to who's talking can you
imagine the man on the streets oh my god
do you ever worry it's going to eat like
you eat you no what I hear this story
every day I hear the story every goddamn
day youing
hacks [__] talking [__] is Randy safe
Randy is fine and ry's never gonna we're
never gonna they're never going to be oh
it is big it is big he's the best cuz
all of them are babies like all of our
snakes will get this big but we have to
wait years wow their colors are he
really pretty and I bought him from okay
so I went to the um why do you need six
though here's the thing once you get a
reptile you're like we need all the
reptiles they're so beautiful they're so
cool there's all these different breeds
and my dad always asks how's Todd cuz he
met him that one time in Palm Springs
and I'm like well Todd is addicted to
reptiles and he had to come out he had
to come out to me before the engagement
he did and I was like yeah he's like I'm
a reptile guy how soon before like how
into the relationship did he come out
about the reptiles it was like 6 months
ago there's a lot of guys on
like you have you're up to 15 okay so I
went to the reptile Super Show this is
it's outside of there to do man on the
street and Todd I'm always out of town
when it's when it's happening so Todd's
always like FaceTiming me and I'm like
why are you not paying attention he's
like he's always like in this frenzy and
I'm like what do you just leave the
reptile you're being crazy and then I
went and I was like like the first thing
I saw was this gecko I don't know what
kind of gecko it is but it's like it's
got eyes like this big I started crying
I was like I need one it's so cute
they're just it's like moving Living Art
and it's like so fun to take care of
them I got a pine snake um a couple like
a month ago and that was going to be my
snake and I was going to like train him
to want to hang out with me and stuff
yeah but he had been when I when I first
saw him we were in at the reptile store
and they they didn't have a a big
enclosure for him yet so he was just
living in this like little box and I
felt so bad for him and I was like oh my
God I want to rescue you and he was like
looking at me he was like get me out of
here and then he immediately like
burrowed into the dirt and I've never
seen him again
and I was like [__] I was like I want my
snake and then people at the reptile
store were like oh you can just put less
dirt in but I was like I can't he's too
happy he's like yeah living his best
life so then I was like I'll just get
another snake do you feel like the snake
loves you like do you feel the love from
like he hugged me okay so when I went to
the reptile there's like all of these
different booths and stuff and there was
a booth Booth with all girls there was
one it was a trans boy too but I we had
to go through the process of me finding
that out but um immediate misgender I
was like look at all these hot lady
sorry my bad but so I was like what's
the story what's going on here and so
the woman told me that her husband had
been cheating on her for 22 years and
she found out and he left her with all
of these Snak so she was it was her
divorce sale so I had to buy oh my go
gosh do you feel like your love of
reptiles is influenced by your love of
Todd or do you think you like already
loved reptile
I think I would never if it if I was
dating any of my ex-boyfriends and they
tried to pull this [__] on me I would
have been like you would have been like
get out go yourself but I was very it
it's exciting to see Todd excited about
something and doing something Todd like
works so hard he's always working so
it's you don't think you don't think it
was just like a sort of a latent love of
reptiles that you hadn't discovered I've
always liked I've always been like a
pickme girl in the sense of like I've
always wanted to like appear tough cuz I
have brothers I don't know I always
wanted to like be like let's not pick me
trying to be like cool to my brothers
and like I would say like oh I don't
know I always was like trying to be like
fit in with the guys not afraid of
spiders and stuff but then it became the
truth and then I'm not like afraid of
anything and my mom was really afraid of
snakes she there's like one of our
stories that she always tells which I'm
like you you can stop telling this one
we were like little babies she had two
you know I my twin brother and then my
older brother's two and a half years
older so we were so little and we were
in a canoe at um her cousin's place in
Vermont and they a
and she in the canoe where they put the
rope that ties the canoe up she there
was like a bunch of snakes and my mom's
like deathly for them so she just
dropped us and abandoned us in the canoe
honestly relatable I would the same
thing so I think because I was like well
my mom's kind of a [__] I've always
been like maybe I'll get a bunch of
snakes which how does she feel about the
snakes she's cute about it I think that
I think that we started watching all
these reptile YouTubes and stuff and I
think a lot of the the these reptile
places kind of help people get over
these fears and I love conquering fears
you know that [__] I love to like
whatever I'm afraid of I like to do it
and have the high afterwards of
surviving and so I do think that we
we're we're raising like good snakes I
hate conquering fears really I love it I
really hate it I I have no interest in
conquering a fear I just if I'm afraid
of something I'm like that's not for me
yeah yeah I'm like no I'm good I kind of
lean more towards that like I still I
still haven't learned how to ride a bike
or Swim so the fact that you started
doing drugs in any way was the wildest
thing I've I I never thought I would see
it I I could when did you start smoking
weed literally it was all because of my
miscarriage which is sort of sad but
rock on um I miscarriage is sort of
sad after my DNC the surgery where they
like take it out cuz it was it's called
a DNC a DNC yeah oh DNC I was like DNC
the DNC is always trying to get rid of
babies yeah so after uh that I like a
couple days after the surgery I was it I
just had this horrible pain like
bleeding really really bad on the floor
of the bathroom like I think I'm going
to die never felt so bad and then I was
like oh my God I just remember they gave
me prescription pain pills go get them
took one fell high the first time in my
life and was like I I'm so happy I love
this and then I was telling some of my
guy friends I was like you guys I tried
hydrocodone and it is awesome I want to
do it more and they're like who like no
no no don't do that don't do that then
one of them was like I think what you're
looking for is just like weed and I was
like okay and then I that's when I like
tried an edible I'm so glad you're not a
pill head can you imagine Esther was
just a pill head God the constipation
alone I would I can't I don't even I I
avoid painkillers at all costs because
of that awful being constipated is a is
my now I do still take a half a one when
I get get really bad period cramps and
that does really help me like I'm still
pampering 1982 if you decide to do a
C-section make sure that you they they
like will give
you like fenel and whatever and like
just make sure that they don't if you
want to be like present enough to like
remember it there's like an anxiety
thing that they can give you without you
getting likeed up and um really is that
what you did yeah wait so did were you
really mild on the pain stuff because of
addiction
yeah I didn't so like everything I was
like once uh we do it so different I'm
like freels no like once they were done
I was like just give me Tylenol and moin
I'll just I'll just take that was it
hard to not cuz you can't really laugh
and [__] when you have a C-section yeah
but nothing was funny anyway you're like
Andy You' turned into a hack funny yeah
I was like this sucks like nothing was
funny everything was so real and I was
so like everything just felt like like I
would try to write a joke and I'd be
like like I feel like that's going to
hurt somebody's feelings like I've never
thought that in my life and it was I was
like this is crazy and then after like a
month I was like all right I'm
back now how long did your C-section
hurt I felt better literally the day of
my c-section I felt better than I did
pregnant so I I truly that's like how
much pain I was in you know so it was it
was great I was I was up I was walking
around it was hurt it was painful but it
wasn't anything compared to carrying
around a fetus it really sucks huh it
sucks it's so bad what are you GNA do
with your placenta I don't want to I
don't know her I don't I don't want to
know her I don't want to know her did
you do something with that no I'm good I
I don't remember did Whitney I feel like
Whitney would have done something so
weird with it like she probably like
drugged us with it at some point like we
probably ingested
herent when did the placenta eating
thing start was that the Kardashians
that started that it no it had it had to
started do it though it's so funny to
see a dog give birth and nasty they eat
the bags yeah it's so cute I don't know
about cute I know I remember being so
traumatized my dog had puppies when I
was like eight and I was the first best
life experience ever I was horrified
tell us everything you're dog had
puppies yes my parents her and it was
they took her to this she was a bichan
they took her to this like Farm she
definitely got like everyone was in
bread everything was in bread she came
back she smelled so bad I remember we
were like driving her back from the it's
like we just took our dog to like a gang
we got our
dog she was already like an autistic dog
that you like pet her and she removes
herself from the room yeah you have like
if she laid on you you'd be like don't
move Pink's going to stay and then you'd
like touch her or like have any joy and
she was out she was like I'm not here
for you and she was probably like you
got me raped which was how I felt about
my parents for a long time my grandma's
dog over the holidays was sexually
assaulted and got pregnant by you no
your grandma's dog was sexually
assaulted yeah she they all of a sudden
one day they were like she's not feeling
well and they took her in and they're
like she's pregnant but all the puppies
didn't make it and they had to give her
an emergency surgery she got a DNC yeah
well that's more that happens like all
the time with dogs like one of them
doesn't make it right if they have like
multiple they have yeah a bunch it
happens with snakes too guys wait what
are you going to have how do snakes give
birth like I feel like they'd have to do
it out of their mouth oh right they lay
come from where there's there's a little
there's a little I had a snake in
college there's a little in college yeah
damn you were like I'm never getting
laid Yeah well I in closeted so oh
you're closeted you're like I need a I
need something [__] likee in my room
yeah exactly so they lay eggs how big
are the eggs they're I mean I think it
depends I think they're like like this B
can be really big and they can be like
soft too like really soft do you want me
to bring the snake in yeah I was just
going to ask that I kind of wish you'd
brought it in today I know I can't care
about your feelings anymore you and me
will be on the same it's been nine
months I can't it's like so many months
it's like I can't I can't be going so
easy on you I would as long as it
doesn't touch me I'm fine I just don't
I'm not ready to touch a snake pregnant
I'm excited to see how Kila reacts
she'll probably be into it or not
wouldn't it be fun if there was a Twist
there's always sometimes there's a twist
with Kila you don't know yeah that's
true what's kila's sign uh none of know
Scorpio oh Scorpio Scorpio okay all
right what's yours Pisces Pisces me too
wi your birthday um March 16th do you
know what sucks about being a cancer is
I can never wear the necklace everyone
can wear their it's like you can't wear
cancer around your neck but
honestly we don't need to wear Pisces
around our neck nobody needs to be
wearing their sign around the I think
that's good for you I think this is good
yeah but I hear you're saying it is the
worst name for
all and it's 69 you could wear the sign
the 69 sign yeah that's fun and then you
get a lot out of that you guys get a fun
sign yeah yeah it is fun mine is the
water whatever and I can't swim so I
have to live with that you can swim you
just don't you just don't want
to I can't swim put it I choose not to I
always think of Esther as the little the
baby on Nana just throw her in the thing
with the little penis throw her in the
pool tiny little baby and's a cancer I
know I think that's why we get along
yeah yeah he is a cancer too so I know I
dated a Cancer and I was like I can't is
there do you think there's truth to that
cuz my best childhood best friend and
Dave are both the same sign is that like
a thing are we truth to what that we you
didn't say the thing like why only dated
Gemini you can't read my mind
yet um that like you get a you have the
same sort of similar connection with
people who have the similar like both
I've never dated the same sign over and
over like I I that's happened to me I
only dated Geminis my whole life it's I
can't believe it are you a Gemini no I'm
a cancer but I'm just saying every guy
I've ever dated has been a Gemini Dave
and Christina are Geminis yeah I've
never dated the same sign I've always
it's always been a different sign have
you had any okay so like this past you
like water you don't have yeah I'm kind
of like well that didn't work let's try
some now I'm not like water I can
confirm I don't go with any flow I
actually don't feel like I'm very Pisces
from when I like when I read the
description so fake and stupid come on
but Annie you just cuz your necklace now
we're all on this no I asked I asked I
asked what K was I know well signs are
like yeah she did start it [__] you
have to just put it on me [__] Pisces
[__] such a Pisces thing to do I don't
know anything about the signs but it's
fun to play with I always say like with
like tarot and stuff it's like if I
start to like if I go to see a psychic
like I'm not doing well like if I'm like
I'm like I could have told you that yeah
but it is like so like it's fun for like
a date idea you know what I mean that's
if you go on like a date and you get
your tarot cards read that's like like a
fun date that does sound fun it's like a
fun silly thing very scary I had a Tarot
reader at my birthday party and it was a
huge hit yeah that's like a fun just
tell oh do you know what I actually had
done at my sex party my New Year sex
party it wasn't my party I went to a
party there was a guy who did tea tree
tea leaf readings like Harry Potter so
they do is that what he did well the
woman did you are yes something Julian
you are something it must have been hard
to stay in that closet it must have been
you must have been clinging at the door
you just wanted to bust open and show
like [__] shivering cold ja cold Dark
Universe alone oh my God he was just you
had a dildo in that closet with you
didn't
you wait so what was the sex party it
was okay so New Year's I I was like
texting the girls I was like what are
you guys doing for New Year's I saw a
movie with my parents I also was texting
you oh cuz you were like stuck at home
and I was like I'm at home I I made the
mistake of I watched my niece who's a
toddler while my sister went to a
concert cuz my sister's pregnant again
and I was like this is the last time
she's going to get to do a New Year's
like where she like gets to go all out
so I was like I'll watch Lucy but like
my family was in town for like forever
they just kept coming like in waves and
then my sister came and I was like I'll
watch Lucy and then so it was just like
I was like this is like the worst I
can't it's so rough and I was like I
can't do this I wanted to stay home for
for the holidays because I thought okay
we have a newborn like it's easy
everyone came to us everyone was like
we're coming to see the baby and I was
like okay I it just feels like never end
like the holidays like it's just they're
just never going to end yeah it's
they're they're forever and we're never
going to escape and it's I guess we're
lucky our families love us I think New
Year's Eve should be canceled I I think
it's so stupid I love New Year's Eve why
your birthday I've always loved New
Year's Eve I'm like movie with my
parents go to bed early I love that
feeling wake up refresh the next day I
don't know I oh my god when I drank New
Year's was like New Year's Eve was just
so I love wake up in some weird Brooklyn
apartment new boyfriend I'm like oh I
have a new boyfriend and I want to get
to the sex party obviously I'm wet but
what like what is your what is the New
Year's Eve that you were wanting that
would be so great so like this
judgmental phas work on this [__] maybe
maybe I'll let let her live New York is
different like I was just telling them
like New York you have like this big
community of people that you love that
you they're like your family you stay up
until 700 a.m. you come out of the bar
the sun's coming up you're just like arm
in-arm with each other it's like it
doesn't matter sober drunk like my I
could be standing next to somebody fully
on Molly and it's like I am telling them
that I love them you know what I mean
it's like it doesn't I just like love
New Year's Eve I love being with people
celebation it's a it's like a cular
ending and beginning it's so fun there's
so much pressure on New Year's to I
don't feel that pressure I think it'sing
I don't know it's like it's a new year
it doesn't feel like pressure to me it
feels like it's like a birthday we're
all having at the same time yes and some
people don't like their birthdays I love
my birthday I love yeah I don't like my
birthday but I love New Year's Eve why
don't you like your birthday because
it's all about me and I don't like
that's embarrassing yeah it's like and
then you you have a party and you invite
a bunch of people and it's always the
one that you don't want to that shows up
first and you're like oh God but as the
birthdays go on didn't want you to come
the birthdays go on those invites stop
going out I was talking all my
girlfriends that I hung out with in
Santa are like in their late 40s and 50s
I was saying how I really want to stop
and I've been working on just like like
I I don't want to like put myself out
for other people's feelings anymore it's
just like so disrespectful to myself
like I just want to be with my
boundaries and stop like you know yeah
it might not be good for you but um my
end up bad for you no like but can I
just I'm sorry to keep interjecting here
but like this has been a huge thing for
pregnancy that I'm realizing is when
you're pregnant I can't put my mask on
before someone else's because the that's
taking over for me and it and I don't
operate well like that I need to put my
mask on meet my needs so that I can be
great for everyone else it doesn't so
yes I've never I've never seen you as
someone that doesn't put their mask on
First and that's why pregnancy is not
easy oh I serious I oh I see what you're
saying no pregnancy is like I I need I
need to take care myself I admire that
part of pregnancy and I'm like oh that
would be so nice to be like only living
to take care of this thing but I yeah
it's the opposite it's really hard but
so yes like that is the I think all
women need to be a little more selfish
but they were saying my but my
girlfriends were saying they're like
well welcome to your 40s like that's
this is the decade of that it's like
going to rule yeah who okay that's good
so when I turn 40 in 10 years it'll be
so
wait so tell us about the sex party okay
so I met these uh these guys Todd and I
were watching these guys um Danny Burke
and Reckless Ben they do they on you
they have YouTube channels where they
infiltrate Cults and Todd for like
months has been like you we've got to
get these guys on on annwood we've got
to like hang out with these guys these
guys are so cool because they're these
Surfers and they'll be like they'll go
into these Cults and like they were like
not saying chill things about black
people like they talk like Surfers but
they're it's just so they're so funny
but so I went and did a he was talking
to me about it I go drive to La Hoya to
do The Comedy Store my friend Bobby was
opening for me he's like oh my friend
Danny's here he's like so cool he's got
this YouTube channel where he
infiltrates Cults and I was like this is
so weird I'm meeting you right now
because my fiance's been talking about
you non-stop yeah and so then we like
connected they came on the podcast and
we just hit it off they're just like
they're so cute and it's so funny when
you get like one inch away from Comedy
people people are just precious and
sweet and nice and kind and loving and
supportive um so they just became our
friends and so then it's like you know
three days later it's New Year's and and
this guy Danny Burke is like what are
you guys doing for New Year's I'm like
oh my God these are going to be like our
New Year's plans and we weren't really
planning on anything we're like maybe
just going to stay in because we're so
tired from traveling from the holidays M
and he goes well there's like Ben's
girlfriend's having this party I don't
know if we're going to go or not it was
him and his girlfriend and they send us
the flyer it's the sex party it's just
the flyer is just a girl with [__] all
over her face and we were like well I
guess we got to go to that that reminds
me of the banana bread that my mom made
that had a cinnamon icing on top how oh
got it I was like how interesting so we
had similar New Year's Eve keep going no
totally like after you ate it
yeah I'm sure there was some acid reflux
going on in the sex party too right A
little regurgitating
yeah what was going on so we go it's
like in it was like in this Warehouse
downtown you had to like step over like
so many scary homeless people um was
Pitch Black inside no no no to get in it
was wild and then we get there and it
was they had like the tea tree readings
or the leaf readings they had VR set up
and then they had a stage where there
was like just different type of like
what was the VR setup it I honestly
thought it was going to be a lot of like
jizz coming on our faces but it was they
I think they're just coming up the the
group of artists that threw this party
are coming up with their own VR system
or something so it was more just like I
was on mushrooms too so I was like I was
like this is so weird cuz it was like
them rock climbing earlier that day it
was like all the people that had put the
headset on me but they were doing an
activity that I was like watching I was
like can I just go rock climbing with
you did you and Todd have sex in public
no nobody was really
banging we weren we there was one sex
room it was a little bit disappointing
in that in I think it was actually the
girl who was in the flyer was like
giving a [__] it was fun like the guy
like as we like walked by this guy was
like looking Us in the eye as this girl
was blowing him that was fun that was
just like for well when you go to a sex
party you want to see some sex and we
left kind of early we left at 1: but
they were at the strike of midnight they
were there was a woman on stage um
whipping a trans girl and um and then
they tied her to a steak and tried to
light her on fire but it didn't work it
was very funny it was so crazy tried to
light her on fire funny it was funny it
wasn't working it was funny they were
like panicking you know Annie going to a
sex party very gay of you no I want to
go to more I want to go to like the
places where you have to like be a
member or whatever see this is an
example of something that before
pregnancy I was like really really
wanted to do and now I'm like I don't
have an interest in that good example
yeah no I I wouldn't I don't have the
same interest that I think you might
have had like I'm not going to I'm just
curious like you have a curious brain I
would also just want to walk like just
see what what's going on I have like a
sex party scene in this movie I'm
writing too so I kind of want to like
get inel which I know sounds fake but I
I'm going for resarch no I just I'm like
I feel like um
going I swear I'm just not horny like
I'm like not I I'm barely horny I'm
barely hor don't care anymore like when
people talk about sex I'm like grow up
that's how I feel I'm aging out of like
I have to do a special because I'm like
aging out of my jokes I'm like oh this
weird to tell people about my squirting
I just out before I'm horrified it's so
weird right it like starts to happen
where you're like you're listening to
your own [__] talk about sex and I'm
like I think this is natural like with
comedy especially like if you don't look
back at your jokes and go like why did I
talk about that then you're not really
getting better but I feel like when I
hear my old jokes I'm just like G God I
suck I'm still like they're very well
written and how cute was I but I'm like
it's just not and it's hard like even
just the changes of my life this past
year like there's some material where
I'm like I can't really I can't really
sell this anymore but I it's but it's
funny but it's like I it's not I don't
got I don't have it well isn't that how
Comedy Works anyway you just like get to
some certain point where you're like oh
my God I'm so beyond all these joke and
they're like should I put this in a
special like oh God right by the by the
time you're ready to shoot the special
you're just like you hate everything
yeah I thought that you the whole the
good thing about getting older is that
you get like hornier and want to have
sex all the time is that not true I
don't feel horny I don't feel that way I
had like a really big Boost from weed
yeah but then pregnancy just obviously
took that all away I'm so afraid of
getting pregnant um that I am just like
so anxious around this but I thought you
were have you kind of worked through
that a little or no um it's still there
it's just you know and like obviously
everyone I know that's pregnant or has
kids is like no they you're never ready
or whatever and I'm like yeah but it's
just like I'm very close to achieving a
specific level that I'm trying to get to
so it's like it would just really it up
but I felt about it I was like it's just
going to everything up that's like how I
felt and I feel like it did for me like
I was like loving standup and I was
planning on doing a special and all this
stuff and then I'm just like that's that
all went away in my first trimester was
like there's no way so that's that's
real and I think having the Frozen
embryos gives me like it's like I sleep
at night but my question did that yeah
same I was like let me freeze them just
so that I can get this pressure off I
was so I couldn't sleep I was like [__]
it and it's so weird I think the thing
with motherhood that like the idea of it
that's like so hard for me is like I
really wish that I just didn't want kids
like I wish I could just say I
absolutely don't want them but I can't
and that's the thing like and but I
can't say like I really want them either
you know so it's like that's what's
stressful I stand by both options are
terrifying I know yeah both are both you
don't win you know when you see like the
comics who like didn't have kids and
they're like talk about it all the time
and you're like it feels like they
aren't okay with it like and it's not my
business and I don't know what people
are thinking so it doesn't matter but
but I'm like I do have like a fear of
that of like wanting to keep like
justifying my decision I always take
people at their word like when they say
that they're happy without having kids I
believe them and maybe they do want to
talk about it because it's like there's
an ABS feel like that's actually
something that like Society does to us
where it's like we won't believe that
women are happy without kids and I think
it's like internalized [__] yeah um and
I think it's unfair that women feel that
we have to prove that we're happy
because we don't when we don't have kids
that's that's up too but I am like I I I
do take their word for it I just feel
like I got to a point where I was like I
don't know if I want them I don't know
if I
don't I feel like I just want to make a
choice and having the embryos allowed me
to be like I have the choice like I I
can make the choice whenever I want and
then obviously I got pregnant like 2
months after freezing embryos like with
but um I liked your guys engagement
photos those were cute likey engagement
photos yeah they were totally like we
were like in a sublet yeah in La did you
know you were going to marry Andy when
you first started dating him I didn't
know that I was going to marry him but I
knew that I wanted to get married and so
I told him I was like Hey I want to get
married so if you don't I just um I I'm
going a we should date other people if
you don't want if you're not open to
like getting married again why did you
why did you want to get married
I've always want I always wanted to be
married I just always like I liked the
idea of having a partner that like you
could do everything with and that you
spend your life with and it's like
there's this kind of thing that you got
to keep going you got to you got to keep
working on yourselves together and I it
was just to me it was really a cool idea
I know people are like it's it doesn't
seem cool to get married I always
thought it was cool I see that now now
I'm very grateful for that but I wasn't
I don't know that I never wanted to get
married I never imagined myself in a
wedding dress or I didn't neither but I
wanted to be married yeah but NE but
with Todd I was he was like the first
guy because there were like boyfriends I
always had I was like like I can't marry
like I got married on ecstasy in Santa
to a boyfriend I had who was cheating on
me all the time and it was like a joke
like kind of like a joke thing like we
didn't sign anything but I remember
being like in my head like I hope this
isn't yeah yeah like legally binding in
anyway this is not a funny joke if this
actually and then other boyfriends like
I did um DMT with one of my
ex-boyfriends and we had such a volatile
like crazy relationship and I came out
of the DMT trip being like it feels like
like the DMT was telling me like I need
to be a mom and he was like I knew you
wanted to have kids I was like not with
you oh my God no no no no not with you I
want the kids to survive right yeah but
it was like it was like I was with these
people I was like very unhealth like
there was never like an option to get
married or have kids cuz the
relationships were so healthy because I
was so unhealthy
seeking out that could work but Todd is
like soid and it was like oh I love
doing everything with you it's like so
fun to be with you all the time yeah do
any of you feel pressure from your
family to like have the kids or get
married like just for them side but not
my side doesn't care but Todd's side
like Todd's parents are in their mid-50s
because Todd's young as hell but so and
they're like but they have like Todd's
dad's a roofer and then his mom is a is
a bank teller or Bank a banker so they
live kind of like their jobs are like
difficult they're like you know going to
the bank every day is like tedious and
then being a someone that does manual
labor they feel like so old and my
parents are in their 70s and 80s and
they Feel So Young you know so it's like
so my parents don't they're like and
they're they have grandkids and so
everyone has grandkids of my in-laws and
my parents but my father-in-law will be
like you got to have kids now Annie like
you know life's over you know I'm like
what are
yeah like I don't feel that way at all
but there's like that but I always tell
Todd's mom she can be the surrogate if
she wants do you want to have them and
raise them and I'll take them when
they're 18 yeah like that's fine I'm
busy [__] you they you all want my do
you want my generational wealth that I'm
working on here yeah yeah yeah or not
yeah you at least like I know you didn't
get to use your embryos but now you have
them so if you ever like yeah throw one
in the surrogate yeah I'm like I I have
six six girls I'm like
girls I have four Bo what wait you guys
all have that's so crazy you both have
all the same and is such a girl dad
though yeah he is he's such a girl dad
that content though every time I see
girl dad content I'm like G God I love I
saw the it always just looks like dad's
trying to get laid for having just for
being a dad to woman great I am I'm like
off I like the thing that I'm like I had
a girl Dad I just called him dad like
it's off
um I like the the thing about people
touching your baby that Andy posted oh
yeah yeah yeah cuz we went to
Thanksgiving and it was like one of my
dad's friends who was like hammered
walked up and was like give me the baby
and I hadn't prepared myself I just
thought nobody did that I just thought
everybody knew not to do that so I
handed her the baby and then I was just
following her around like a free like I
was just like following her around and
finally I just took her I just like
grabbed her out of the woman she was
like what are you doing and I was like
nope she's too new I was like give her
to me it's like fear and lothing in Las
Vegas's like give me the baby he's like
tripping on
stuff and there's it's funny too cuz
it's like people will try to it's you
know we're with Comics so like Comics we
take swings and we'll try to make jokes
and whatever and I remember like we had
a comic over and somebody was like I
think Andy was like oh I wouldn't let uh
I didn't let so and so in the room while
I was changing her diaper and the the
guy was like I tried I tried to watch
and I almost flew across the room I was
like I it wasn't a comic or it was a
comic it was a comic but I was like you
don't make fun that's my kid that's not
your bit you know what I mean I was like
this isn't we're not in a [__] this
isn't aing podcast like I was like
that's mying kid and I to this day like
if anybody tries to make a joke about my
kid I have to physically physically hold
myself back from hitting them like I
it's very difficult who yeah I'm like
it's really fun of your kid it's crazy I
wonder I won't okay thanks don't do it
no I'm not going to do it I have not
even made fun of you you can make fun of
me as a mom you can make fun of Andy as
a dad but you cannot make F I've been
wanting to make fun of her so bad and
then I can't it's like not in me anymore
thank you you're in a different state
she's a different thing yeah it's like
I'm becoming a different it's weird it's
exciting to see though I the pregnancy
is is a boot camp that is changing me
you seem so much better though I don't
feel better I see a lot wor but maybe
you've had to surrender to the feeling
worse I've had to surrender to a lot and
it is I just feel like it is breaking
down every fiber of my being and
rebuilding me every fibroid of her being
and being something different and new
I've never done something for someone
else I've never made this kind of a huge
sacrifice and I can't I'm on you're on
once you're on the ride you can't get
off no it's crazy so it's just I'm
forced to be in this and and I'm letting
it change me I'm obviously kicking and
screaming on my way but like it's
happening yeah and I'm I don't know I'm
also I think this is just pregnancy
hormones and not like changes but I'm
very sensitive no that's real that's a
real change that'll happen that'll last
yeah like I'm so sensitive in ways that
I never have been sensitive well I'm
glad I had the instinct to not make fun
of you well not I don't like
that there's one thing you know it's how
to read a room more like I know how to
read a delivery room it's more just like
I'm I feel this like sensitivity of a
connection with my family and a
closeness and like you have such a cute
family I love your parents so much I
just I don't know or like I when I was
this weekend I did a gig in San Jose and
I know that I've talked about this with
you last summer like I love going on the
road alone I love it it's so fun and
then I was pregnant on the road alone
and I it's all different now you texted
me about this I was it was dark I almost
called you and kalila I it was so dark I
was I just felt alone and isolated and
sad and that's not how I've ever been
before so you're just like what the
there could have been a worst case
scenario you could have been with some
of your past
openers which couldn't be a fate worse
than hell that I mean there's nothing
worse I've always been very shocked at
your choices oh oh okay we're taking a
swing interesting oh wow we want to have
drama but you feel I feel like you have
the road figured out perfectly cuz
you'll have Andy and baby and you get to
do your job try to drive or fly um I
enjoy flying yeah it's interesting like
the like I'm very picky about the
routing now cuz I'm like I'm traveling
with a baby so I want to make sure that
the routing makes sense whereas before
I'd be like yeah take me from here to
here I want the routing to make sense do
you have fadon yeah cuz sometimes like
what is is this like a joke are you with
me yeah yeah I'll be like what is like
you want me to die of of jet lag yeah
yeah yeah I'm like every day I'm like
wait I'm back there wait what's
happening yeah yeah yeah I'm doing like
the Star of David I'm like really
getting into my Judaism I'm like what is
going on no I didn't I just didn't care
before but now I'm kind of like cuz I
was just like I'm in hell anyway like
has to be like a year in advance you
have to figure that out too it's like so
much planning and preparing yeah so I'm
like and I don't don't think like that
like I'm not a planner so I have to show
I'll like show Andy the routing cuz he's
so good at like planning [__] and like
knowing how it's going to play out that
he'll be like oh this doesn't make sense
beyond that I feel like it's pretty much
the same cuz I feel like Natasha did it
so cute too with mosha like where they
just had like a RV just like going
together and bringing the baby seems
great I'm just like Todd do you want to
spot because he was going on the road
with me and I did I had to stop like
even requesting that for him because
it's like he doesn't like traveling and
he doesn't get the glory of the
experience of performing for people so
it's like he should come up on stage at
the end with you we Dave and I did that
a couple tour dates last year and it was
like it was magnificent yeah it is cute
like he should just come up the last 10
minutes he try it he's really funny he
is so what was he saying yesterday he
just said [__] where I'm like this is so
[__] funny is funny oh it was crazy
what he was doing actually I can't
repeat it but it was so so funny do you
guys ever go on stage together Andy and
I yeah oh you do yeah oh so like Andy
will go up first then I'll go up and
then or you know depending on who's
headlining but like and then at the end
we both come up and we just we just
shoot the [__] isn't that so fun it's
really fun it ends up being like really
funny and magical I think you should do
it I always like that's why I was like
going before after you cuz they do stage
I feel yeah I did that too doing it with
my openers is fun yeah cuz I never have
had I always I'm lucky enough that like
my friends will open for me if I'm like
I know that this is you're above this
but can we do this cuz I just want to
have a good time no that's fun I I will
open for people that's really fun I'll
open for my friends too I like it oh my
God Nate pazi was at The Comedy Store
last night it was like so fun to hang
out with him because I just haven't seen
him in so long and I was like I wish I
had a clean 20 and could go on the road
with you it's like he's so C why do you
want a clean 20 because I could CU then
I could go on the road with him he's so
clean he's like squeaky clean so my I
would be his audience would be horrified
by me I'm like oh it would be so
fun I never I've never in my life wanted
to write a clean joke I don't like doing
them I don't yeah it doesn't I mean
sometimes they land clean but it's not
yeah I'm like I guess that's kind of
clean but theme wise it doesn't it's not
clean you know what I mean it's it's
like about death or disease or something
dark dark yeah I don't have a lot of
thoughts that aren't yeah nasty anytime
my anytime my agents have asked me for
like a late night set I'm like what are
you talking about there needs to be late
night sets that are dirty there needs to
be a late night show where we could go
and just do it all I get it now I get it
now with like the SNL thing I'm like
okay I get it I get why it doesn't work
because there's people I mean first of
all advertisers but like there's also
like people in the midwest that are
watching that are like it's it bums them
out like
out for
um good thank you thank you so much
thank you for you guys look great
squeezing Us in on your LA Press trip
are you kidding me press and squeeze you
can't stop thinking about this delivery
and
squeeze kick and fight um thank you so
much and I'm so sad we're out of time I
feel like we could talk forever please
come back I can talk for another 3 hours
I truly I love you guys also next time I
really you to bring the snake I'll bring
the snake I also want to hang out at
Tim's house with you yeah yeah yeah um
but people can watch your set on Netflix
verified which it's so funny and they
can follow you on social media and then
this tour that's coming in May which
will have you and your husband and your
baby yeah hopefully she doesn't spend a
second on stage but I don't know which
is worse like I don't know if it's worse
to take your baby on stage or to let a
waiter watch
them yeah I just feel like it's keeping
them in the back would be I don't but
whatever happens will happen and be fine
and perfect yeah but thank you so much
and thank you to our listeners and we'll
see you guys next week with a brand new
[Music]
episode